[Music]
have you guys
ever blown into that thing
[ __ ] no let me try i forgot how to do it
i forgot
to play your own instrument is it
backwards no it's a special lip
technique i don't know how to do put it
in your mouth more wow just stick it in
your mouth a lot of spit
just put your whole mouth up open your
lips a little yeah there it is
no it's not it's one of those things
like a bottle see if you can reach it
all the way don't blow out
suck in all the way down to like this
mark
i don't think that's the way you do it
no no man try the uh video
let me practice for deep throat
technique
have you guys ever cooked an egg
on the sidewalk thing have you ever
cooked anything you've been that hot
here i've never tried maybe the hood of
your car makes more sense
well here it is california we just went
through like a heat cooking
egg it's not super difficult on a hot
object if you left a skillet outside and
it's a hundred and like 10 degree
weather he said on a sidewalk
i assumed no pan have you ever you have
a pool you don't you don't like walk
without shoes to the pool and you really
like halfway they're like oh [ __ ] it's
too hot
and you're right yeah but not too small
i feel like the that's fine that's
actually
egg cooking temperature is it yeah oh i
don't cook
in your face in my face yeah she tricked
me last time too she was like yeah i
made this and i was like this is really
good gio and then she's like
i just heated it from costco i thought
you were cooking more these days
oh i am but i needed for the joke yeah
but i actually believed her because i
was like damn this macaroni shit's good
and i was like wait a minute it just it
says craft on it
it's at that point it's not my bad no
true true
all right so uh a man who was
hiking at yellowstone national park
nice lucky i heard about this he decided
to take the whole cooking and egg on the
sidewalk concept
a little little further and what other
hikers saw
on the way up the what is it a mountain
on the on the trail uh they saw this guy
and
well at least his party uh of people
carrying let me get this right
two whole birds in a burlap sack how big
were the birds well they were dead or
alive
birds were chickens it does not say
whether they're alive
or dead uh ready to be cooked is that
weird because i mean like
are you trying to say he was doing
something with these birds no he okay so
he was
having sex with these birds that what
you're saying he was carrying a sack of
birds
two birds one second they came in kind
of sauce so i get all the questions
think eggs cooked on a sidewalk this guy
was carrying two
chickens in a burlap sack along with
cookware
okay hiking up a yellowstone uh national
park
okay to a natural geyser okay planning
on
cooking the chickens at the natural oh
wow he's trying to boil it
he's making high knight chicken yeah
he's making chicken yes
i actually thought it was the chinese
guy but they actually don't say
if uh like his nationality or ethnicity
or one of those organic white dudes
who's also a buddhist who's also a
buddhist he might have dreadlocks he for
sure has dreadlocks and he's spitting on
in his hands
featured in doctor strange and was that
his first time
or did he just just so happen to get
caught this time we don't know if it's
his first time or not
and he was definitely caught this time
he was fined a thousand dollars a
thousand two hundred dollars for cooking
in the geyser
for violating closures and use limits
and
serving two years of unsupervised uh
probate probation
so he didn't get in trouble for the
chicken stuff he just got in trouble for
they all ate the chickens after but he
decided to pay the fine
he's like actually this chicken is
pretty bad and i'ma lock you up i'm
curious how he was cooking them
so what he was planning to do is uh he
wanted to i guess use the uh
water as heat as the heat source yeah he
wanted to grill the chickens
on his cookware it's pretty spicy and
basically create an impromptu like a
natural
barbecue pit oh okay but the heat was
from water from
natural hot spoiling it not grilling it
uh no what no grilling has been like
on the pan from water
the water is just the heat source that
sounds like too much work and that
sounds interesting the hiking
or the cooking everything getting the
cheese yes
getting the chocolate bro like going up
to the geyser like bro
bring [ __ ] bolios and [ __ ]
sandwiches you know what i'm saying like
the burlap sack makes me feel like it's
live chickens
yeah he's [ __ ] slinging him on his
shoulder
[ __ ] johnny appleseed trying to eat
some chicken when you go to yellowstone
it's not like
like the store you gotta like it's a
whole [ __ ] trip so he's
taking these chickens he's getting all
the yellow time warp from 1843
and [ __ ] like is he a [ __ ] 49er
only uh he's not penny for gold yeah
he's all panicked he goes i'm hungry
the only information we have on this guy
is that he's from idaho they
they refer to him as the idaho man in
this
article very clever is he like a
youtuber or something does he is he like
bear grylls i know like wild [ __ ] like
what's
what's the reason okay so it doesn't
sound
that odd because if you're just in
nature and then if you're
like if you're just a homesteader like
you cook i mean you grow your own food
but the thing is him going to the geyser
and doing this
okay maybe because my imagination is
imagining the guys are shooting up and
he's hitting
that's what i was picturing today is the
geyser is the question oh it's [ __ ]
hot
it's hot absolutely geyser water reaches
143 degrees fahrenheit on average 143 so
that's that's enough to i guess oh yeah
it's enough to get fatal
third degree burns if you fell into it
yeah
of course but so as far as cooking a
chicken maybe he would have just
dropped the chicken in the oven and then
it just comes back up and just kind of
catches it it's a [ __ ] suv
he's doing he's trying to do shabu bro
that's what it is
all the feathers are gone oh [ __ ] oh so
you do have to de-feather them right
because that's that's
what they do right you put hot water on
a chicken with feathers and you dip it
in the hot water real quick and then you
pluck the feathers
they just hold them out by the legs and
then the guys go pull
and then it's just clean ready to eat
this hold the chicken
but yeah so that it's not the oh it's
not the first time
well actually i think it's the only time
anyone's ever caught something
it's not the first time someone goes but
other people have been hurt so
i think the the reasons why he got in
trouble and why the whole cooking thing
isn't allowed is you're not supposed to
be uh messing around with a geyser's
period you're supposed to stand afar and
take pictures that's a given right yeah
you would think right now i mean
sometimes we should just let natural
selection do what it [ __ ] happens
what i mean and probably die because
there's no way this chicken is going to
be able to be cooked
unless he drops it's not the natural
selection i was thinking of but yes
you guys never i mean it all works out
like a couch
and putting it on top of a geyser and
when it shoots up
you and your buddy could just be like on
the couch you said on cartoon
i know that's way more [ __ ] furniture
over there that corner is expected
[ __ ] i'm really into
this guy brought a couch out of nowhere
yeah or get like a capsule
you're more protected i guess like a
bubble true but that the guys
should get out of the cat just pretty
protecting you because you're gonna get
burned
i'm trying to put myself in this guy's
shoes and i know
i don't think he's wearing shoes bro i'm
trying to put myself in these guys
birkenstocks and i'm trying to figure
out if i would ever do any of this and
i don't know man you never have like the
the curiosity that kind of like
i need i wonder i wonder if i could
survive in the in the wild incredible i
feel like i feel like that
yeah that's stupid that's very different
make a fire man
yeah exactly this fool could do this it
didn't start a fire
and then yeah because there's way easier
ways to cook a chicken in the wilderness
i know that one [ __ ]
boiling geyser but if he cooked it we're
like would you try the chicken
i would yeah i try it i think i can feed
it i'd be down but if it was just like
he figured some [ __ ] out like let's say
he ate a stray bird and he's like dude
this is bomb like geyser water is the
[ __ ] right he goes you know what
i gotta come back here with my chicken
because i i like pigeons better be good
you know like maybe like the traveling
parrot was just not the good one
cage-free yeah cause what if like a bird
was flying and a geyser hit that [ __ ]
and it flew down he's like oh [ __ ] free
food
and he ate and he's like nah i gotta try
chicken and then he had the idea to go
back with chicken
oh [ __ ] so geyser's been cooking birds
for a minute for a while
that's true that's actually very true
because the specifics of what he's doing
yeah
he seems way too confident to be able to
go to a geyser and bring two chickens if
he's never done this before
you're right true that he he went there
with just the things that i needed yeah
he had pots and pans with him
my friend has pots and pans hidden in
secret
camping spots so that when he goes there
that's amazing that's cool yeah he knows
where to go he just digs it up and then
he [ __ ]
[ __ ] map like 14 paces northwest
imagine that's all the treasure maps
back in the day it's just [ __ ]
popular
yeah what happens if he goes back to his
to the spot
and it's gone he's gonna starve not
really
you said this man was not alone what
about the other people yeah he was in a
group
he was those [ __ ] dared his name and
two chickens
yeah yeah he needed help with the two
chickens i'm sure it's like a
quite a they're alive cooking a live
chicken is so much work i would just
ziploc i would prep the chicken put it
in a ziploc do the hike and then cook it
at the spot i'll [ __ ] put it on a
i'll put the chicken on the sword like
this and i just put it on the geyser and
i'm ready to go yeah
this guy did too much work he has to sit
there
and [ __ ] pluck the chickens well
chinese tourists are taking pictures
and then like so the guys is going off
you did all the prep work
and brought a sword and still chose to
cook it at the geyser yeah
i'm so used to his antics i didn't even
catch on to that james
this guy did too much work i would
totally just clean and prep and put in a
ziploc bring it up there
have my sword skewer it this way and
then cook it on the geyser
[ __ ] idiot yeah [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
scumbag
he should have consulted you for if
we're gonna use a geyser
oh yeah yeah yeah if we have we have to
use that that's true
because it seems like the geyser was the
main attraction the chicken's worn i'm
picturing this guy with a fold-out table
he has this out
the chicken comes out and he's all like
plucking the chicken i thought he time
warped there for now he's doing a
mukbang
yeah he's doing a mukbang he's got the
cameras rigged
time warps [ __ ] forgot my foldout table
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] it seems like they planned this
whole thing out it was like it was like
a party
yeah really weird [ __ ] party that i
or what if it was like some sort of like
sacrifice [ __ ]
well there it is oh wait but then why
the cookware oh it's to make the potions
oh yeah of course the potions of course
you catch the blood and drink yourself
to do this potion
the poison long can you guys live in
nature
for if i have guys there's no guys do i
have any other choice
no like you just have a backpack wait do
i have any other choice
am i voluntarily doing this we're doing
it for fun
are we prepped wait have you seen the tv
show uh alone
i heard that show's good that show's fun
so it's like life though
you said that was your life yeah threw a
joke in
yeah keep going too real joe pretty much
um
it's it's 10 people that like have like
survival skills or whatever and then
they get dropped off either into like
you know
british columbia or like north canada in
the arctic or like mongolia or something
like that right
and they're all spread out in this area
and then whoever just survives the
longest gets half a million dollars wait
wait for it survives not survived last
the longest and then every now and then
the whole you just need to
use your words whoever dies last yeah
[ __ ] yeah that's the game last person
getting murdered um
they'll have medical teams come in and
then if you end up losing too much
weight and you're like you know things
are
obviously going so you get checked up
you get you yeah you get pulled out of
the game and stuff like that
um and before you start they give you
like a list of maybe like 10 or 12 items
that you can bring
and you can only bring so many of them
so different people either uh like
choose like i'll take the
the bow and arrow and somebody else will
be like i'll take the fishing line and
then they just kind of like
have to go in there build their shelter
by themselves yeah buy themselves
they're like specialists
yeah and they and they have to just like
document the entire thing or vlog the
entire thing that sounds fun it's a
really fun tv show actually
you guys check it out but point is to
answer the question
do we get an itemized list where we get
to choose you know it's just whatever
you want
oh and i'll survive right now whatever
you fit in a backpack how about that
a briefcase whatever you want to take
because you care that way yeah
even if you were with your friends to
make it easier like you and your bunch
of friends
after seeing this show i feel like i'd
only realistically last like [ __ ]
a couple months bro i'm getting murdered
couple months that's a long that's a
long time
this is assuming you know how to fend
off [ __ ] critters and [ __ ] too well
define wilderness we talking like arctic
we're talking like one apart runyon
canyon no we're talking about like
something simple like i don't know so
the weathers don't go like snow and
stuff
how like the forest here the weather in
california oh yeah yeah like
there's like snow like you you can't so
so let's say let's make it easy
if we're in california yeah i feel like
months yeah like we're not braving like
the arctic winter he's like yeah once it
hits winter we're gonna want to go home
i don't think i think i'll last a week
i'm getting murked bro i think i'm going
months maybe years i'm getting eaten up
by something yeah that's what i'm
thinking
like like revenue insects or mosquitoes
would kill me
what i'll probably trip on something hit
my head and die they love my [ __ ]
blood
i'll i'll be left without blood easy
mosquitoes like me too
[Music]